[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi.
My name is Lisa Wray, and I'm
on the Developer Relations team
at Google.
Today, I'm going to be talking
about the storage access
framework in KitKat.
Specifically, the
client app side.
In our last episode about
the storage access framework,
we saw the new
system documents UI
that lets the user of
your app browse content
from all apps on the device
that share documents.
Today, we're going to walk
through how to launch the UI
and how to handle the
results in your app.
There's more to it
than there used to be.
New in Android KitKat
are document editing,
writing, and saving in
place, and document creation
and deletion.
Here's a quick
picture of the flow.
As you can see, document
providers and clients
don't interact directly,
just as before.
A client requests permission
to interact with files, read,
edit, create, et cetera.
The system picker goes to
each registered provider
and shows the user
the matching content.
Finally, the user
selects a document,
and the system grants the
client app permissions just
for that URI.
Let's talk about
ACTION_OPEN_DOCUMENT.
This isn't much different than
what you may have done before.
You're going to
create an intent.
CATEGORY_OPENABLE
means we only want
results that can be
opened-- basically
documents-- as opposed to a
list of contacts or time zones.
The type is the document
MIME type you want.
Here, I'm asking for
any type of image.
And then launch your
intent with a request code.
This can be any value
you like, but it
should be unique
within your app.
And we've launched
the file picker.
Next, the user
selects a document,
and it's back to your app.
Retrieving a URI is
also the same as before.
We get a callback
in onActivityResult.
We check the request
code matches,
and the result came back OK.
Now, we don't get back the
specific document directly,
here.
We get a URI pointing to
it using intent getData.
If you've done this before with
the getContent or pick intents,
nothing's changed.
And this might
look familiar too.
With a URI, we can get
metadata about the image.
Here this query applies
to only one document,
and we want all
the rows, so that's
what all those nulls are for.
Here I'm getting its
display name-- note
that this is not the same as
its file name-- and its size.
You can't count on getting a
reliable size for a document,
because it might be stored
remotely, for example.
So always check that it
isn't null before you try
and get the size.
But forget metadata.
You probably want
to open this image.
Here's a shortcut.
You can use ContentResolver
openFileDescriptor.
You pass in the URI and
the access mode you want,
and you get back a
parcelFileDescriptor,
which is a wrapper
around a FileDescriptor.
For images, there's
a handy method
in BitmapFactory,
decodeFileDescriptor.
Don't do this on the UI thread.
Do in the background.
Use an async task.
There's an example of this in
the storage client sample code
that we're posting.
And finally, it's best practice
to wrap the close in a try
finally block, so it's
guaranteed to close.
And then you can set this
image to an image view.
And here it is.
Now wait, you're saying, I
want to do something else,
or I don't have an image.
Easy.
You can get an inputStream
from the ContentResolver
and do whatever
you want with it.
Here I'm reading the lines
of my file into a string.
So here's a new one.
We weren't able
to do this before.
You can get an outputStream
from the ContentResolver.
By default, it uses write mode.
You want to ask for the least
amount of access you need,
so don't ask for read/write
if all you need is write.
When I'm done, I just
let the document provider
know I'm done by closing
the stream, which
you have to do anyway.
Simple.
So we could open
one document before.
What about lots of
documents at the same time?
All you have to do to let
the user select multiples
is add EXTRA_ALLOW_MULTIPLE
to your intent.
If you want, you can
specify multiple MIME types.
This time we get back clip data.
It's then stored in
intent getClipData,
and you can get the URIs using
clipData getItems and then
item getUri.
Note that you
still have to check
intent getData, the
same as a single URI,
because if the user
picks just one document,
it doesn't matter if you
allowed multiple selection,
it's still coming back the
first way, in intent getData.
So you have to check both.
Creating a document is
also new in Android KitKat,
and it's really straightforward.
You give your intent a
MIME type, a file name,
and you launch it with
a unique request code.
The rest is taken
care of for you.
You get back its URI in
onActivityResult, and that way,
you can continue to write to
it or whatever else you want.
And deleting a document
is even easier.
You can't launch an intent
to delete a document,
but if you have its
URI, which you would
if you've opened or created it,
then you can ask to delete it,
and DocumentsContract
does this for you.
Again, in a document's
metadata, you
can check document column flags.
If that contains
support delete, you'll
know whether to
enable or disable
your Delete button
or Menu option.
One more thing to mention.
When you open a file
for reading or writing,
the system gives you a URI
permission grant for that file.
It lasts until your
device restarts.
However, you might
want to access
that file again directly
from your applications.
Say you're an image
editing app, and you
want to show the user the last
five images they've edited.
If the device is turned
off in the meantime,
you won't have access to those.
You could send the user
back to the document picker,
but that's far from ideal.
Instead, you can
persist the permissions
the system gave you.
Now they'll last no matter
whether the phone is
turned off or on.
The system won't do this
automatically for you.
Your app has to
explicitly request
that the permissions
be persisted.
This is a security measure,
though, so it's a good thing.
One last note.
You may have saved the most
recent URIs your app accessed,
but you should still always use
ContentResolver.getPersistedUriPermissions
to check that you have
the freshest data.
Other applications
could delete documents,
apps could be removed,
so make this check
to make sure your data's right.
That's all for now.
Hope you enjoyed learning
about the new storage access
features in Android KitKat.
Thanks for watching, and
happy document sharing.